y
[Música]
el presidente peruano pedro castillo
anunció que renovará el consejo de
ministros y nombrará a un tercer
gabinete en los seis meses que lleva en
el gobierno la nueva crisis se produce
tras la dimisión de la presidenta del
consejo de ministros mirtha vásquez
conectaremos con lima
salieron a la luz los hallazgos del
esperado informe de su grey en reino
unido la alta funcionaria que investigó
las fiestas clandestinas en la
residencia oficial del primer ministro
denunció fallas de liderazgo y juicio en
el gobierno de boris johnson
analizaremos en esta emisión
y las tensiones en la frontera ucraniana
llegaron al consejo de seguridad de
naciones unidas washington acusó a moscú
de planear enviar más tropas a belarús y
rusia señaló a estados unidos de querer
generar histeria además la casa blanca
quiere que qatar sea un principal aliado
no miembro de la otan
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
gusto saludarlos y comenzamos esta
emisión en perú el presidente pedro
castillo deberá conformar un nuevo
gabinete luego de que la primera
ministra mirtha vásquez renunciara a su
cargo vázquez anunció de su cuenta de
'twitter' que dimitía ante la
imposibilidad de llegar a un consenso
que beneficie al país esto obliga a
castillo a nombrar un tercer gabinete en
tan sólo seis meses que lleva en el
cargo la nueva crisis ministerial se
desata luego de la renuncia del titular
de la cartera del interior avelino
guillén tras la controversia con el
entonces jefe de la policía por ascensos
en la institución vamos hasta lima donde
estaba nuestro corresponsal francisco
zacarías francisco buendía y explíquenos
cuáles fueron las razones detrás de la
división de la presidenta del consejo de
ministros
buenas tardes mirtha vásquez ha
criticado las indecisiones y la falta de
liderazgo del presidente pedro castillo
por sancionar las irregularidades y
posibles actos de corrupción cometidos
por algunos funcionarios y es que en
realidad existen muchas denuncias entre
ellas la del teniente general de la
policía peruana javier bueno quien
reveló que para el proceso de ascensos
de algunos oficiales se exigían pagos
ilegales de dinero de tres que iban
entre 25 mil a 40 mil dólares para
aquellos oficiales que querían ascender
al cargo de general esto fue puesto de
manifiesto por adaptarse a poco ministro
del interior- avelino guillén quien les
señaló al presidente pedro castillo
estas irregularidades y les recomendó
que era necesario cambiar al director de
la policía el general javier gallardo
pero el pedró casio no le hizo caso y el
mismo terminó dinamitando se podría
decir a su propio equipo de gobierno y
como conformaría pedro castillo este
nuevo gabinete y sobre todo cómo lograr
un equilibrio que le garantice la
gobernabilidad
diversos sectores le están pidiendo al
presidente pedro castillo que convoqué a
ministros que tengan un perfil
profesional con experiencia con
liderazgo y con buen manejo político
pero va a ser muy difícil para el
mandatario poder convocar a estos
profesionales porque se señala que tras
el maltrato que ha recibido él hasta
hace poco ministro del interior- avelino
bien y la misma primer ministra mirtha
vázquez va a ser muy difícil se vocea
por ahora
el ministro de salud fernando ceballos
sería el nuevo primer ministro pero este
ha dejado en claro que no tiene
intenciones de asumir el puesto es un
momento muy difícil para pedro casi o
convocar un nuevo gabinete ministerial
porque como señaló hay profesionales que
no están dispuestos a poner en juego su
prestigio por sumarse en apoyo a este
nuevo equipo de gobierno de pedro
castillo gracias francisco zacarías por
este reporte ahora pasamos al reino
unido el primer ministro británico está
en el centro de las críticas luego de
que hoy se revelarán los hallazgos del
informe de la alta funcionaria británica
subraya esto sobre el escándalo conocido
como parís gate en el reporte de 12
páginas revela las conclusiones de las
16 reuniones que investigó y que se
hicieron en downing street en pleno
confinamiento por la pandemia el informe
indica que hubo fallas de liderazgo por
parte del gobierno de boris johnson
mientras que el premier pidió disculpas
ante el parlamento y prometió reformas
internas vamos a ciudad de méxico donde
está fausto pretelín analista
internacional señor pero también
bienvenido a france 24 empecemos
hablando de came obtendrás las
revelaciones de este informe en la
bancada conservadora crecerá la presión
para que boris johnson abandone el cargo
antes de su caída en la popularidad
retamar y aclara buenas tardes y después
es un informe que no necesariamente es
completo porque 11 de los 16 eventos
sociales testigos
en realidad no no hay una gran
información y la propia su grey habla de
que en este momento la policía de
scotland yard está investigando
esos eventos sociales y por eso no puede
hablar evidentemente el informe no es
tan contundente desde el punto de vista
de que si dice que falta liderazgo hay
errores de liderazgo del primer ministro
ya se sabía simplemente lo confirman
pero creo que de alguna forma vendrán
mucho más contundentes las revelaciones
y los señalamientos de la policía en un
futuro cercano no creo que el informe si
ese sí es crítico pero me parece que no
es contundente y no no va a concluir
nada creo que la oposición entiende muy
bien que más allá del informe el primer
ministro británico mintió ante el
parlamento y tiene que renunciar y usted
critica este reporte pero no es el único
ahora reino unido está a la espera de
las conclusiones de la investigación
policial cuál podría ser el alcance de
los hallazgos de la policía
bueno yo creo que hay un efecto ahí de
una enorme responsabilidad que tiene el
primer ministro que es el que generó las
pautas de confinamiento durante la etapa
dura de la pandemia y él es el primero
en violar esas esas indicaciones que le
hace a los británicos particularmente a
los ingleses y creo que de alguna manera
pues él hoy sí reconoce que cometió
error como lo ha dicho anteriormente
pero su alcance de credibilidad en la
sociedad británica es mínimo el mismo
boris johnson el día de hoy dijo y se
preguntó confían usted se preguntarán si
confían en el gobierno británico yo nos
diría que sí que hay que confiar el
gobierno británico me parece que ya es
es una reacción desesperada que tiene el
primer ministro y muy brevemente cómo
queda la policía después de haberse
negado en un principio a investigar las
denuncias
bueno yo creo que la presión política es
la que de alguna manera ha ayudado a que
haya este tipo de investigación creo que
la policía evidentemente primero quizás
queda muy debilitada desde el punto de
vista que trató de proteger al primer
ministro
pero me parece que la scotland yard va a
ser contundente en las resoluciones sí
pero insisto el tema político es ese y
va a traer oposición hasta donde llega
con el primer ministro gracias señor
pretelín por esta información en otras
noticias de eeuu quieren que qatar sea
un aliado principal no miembro de la
otan así lo anunció el presidente joe
biden quien reportará al congreso sus
intenciones luego de reunirse en la casa
blanca con el emir qatarí también bin
hamad al-thani esta es una movida
estratégica en medio de la tensión entre
rusia y ucrania pues qatar es el mayor
proveedor mundial de gas natural licuado
y su suministro sería vital si el
kremlin decide presionar a europa
restringiendo el flujo de hidrocarburos
las tensiones fronterizas en europa del
este también fueron el centro del debate
en la reunión del consejo de seguridad
de la onu aquí les explicamos
tengo 10 votos a favor dos votos en
contra 3 abstenciones
la agenda profesional ha sido adoptada
una rápida votación en el consejo de
seguridad de la onu frustró los intentos
de moscú de bloquear una reunión pública
sobre el conflicto en ciernes cerca de
las fronteras de ucrania la mayoría del
órgano de 15 miembros apoyó mantener la
sesión abierta con china uniéndose a
rusia en el voto en contra y las
abstenciones de los tres restantes el
embajador ruso desestimó la reunión como
una mera maniobra de relaciones públicas
de eeuu
esta es la búsqueda de nuestros colegas
estadounidenses para generar histeria en
torno a su propia narrativa sobre la
supuesta inminente agresión rusa
esta escalada e histeria traerá daño a
la propia ucrania la reunión fue
solicitada por eeuu en medio de los
crecientes temores de una escalada el
conflicto con la esperanza de que pueda
ser el comienzo de un diálogo
diplomático y realmente se trata de las
preocupaciones de rusia en materia de
seguridad en europa
les estamos ofreciendo la oportunidad de
abordar esas preocupaciones en la mesa
de negociaciones
de la prueba de la buena fe de los rusos
en los próximos días y semanas es que
vendrán a esa mesa y se quedarán en ella
hasta que lleguemos a un entendimiento
weybridge en anders tiende desde el
inicio del conflicto se han desplegado
más de 100.000 soldados a lo largo de la
frontera con ucrania el mayor despliegue
militar en europa en décadas sin embargo
rusia siguen negando las afirmaciones de
una invasión o ataque inminente
la junta militar de burkina faso que
lideró el golpe de estado la semana
pasada anunció que ya tiene un nuevo
presidente el portavoz de la junta dijo
que el nuevo líder sería el teniente
coronel paul henri sand ahogó tamib a
los militares también promulgaron una
normativa conocida como la ley
fundamental que regirá la gestión del
poder estatal a la espera de una carta
de transición y que también restablece
de manera parcial la constitución
suspendida desde el día de la toma del
poder
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]